zeisser with us uh jan zeisser is a
professor in
physics at the free university in berlin
uh he has
uh you know very wide-ranging interest
in theoretical physics and
and uh lots of different results across
the spectrum
um but today he'll talk uh about how to
sort of better connect the theory of
quantum supremacy
uh with the experiment in particular the
experiment of quantum simulations
uh and he'll talk us he'll talk to us
about uh anti-concentration
uh a sort of important sort of component
of the theory
of quantum supremacy uh okay so let's uh
let's turn it over to jens now
yes wonderful that's correct um thanks
so much indeed thanks for the kind
invitation
thanks to the organizers for all the
effort and sweat of setting up this uh
wonderful
uh workshop and also for pursuing this
as a
as a virtual event in these somewhat
awkward um
times so today's supremacy monday
and indeed in this talk i will be trying
to be
pretty much faithful to this uh theme
when we have a look at efforts that are
aimed at
what could be called the closing of
conceptual and mathematical loopholes of
showing a quantum advantage
for quantum simulators or quantum
supremacy for that matter even though
the term has fallen
slightly in this favor recently for its
somewhat awkward undertones
now there's literally knowing that the
development as well as the excitement
about actually building quantum
computational devices
is uh going to the roof recently
i mean several protagonists largely from
the u.s
industrial sector including google and
ibm have reported the development of
superconducting devices of an
intermediate
size ranging from like 50 to
a 100 um cubits and even if they may be
noisy and
the devices may fall short of being
fully fall tolerant short class quantum
computers it does seem fair to say that
such devices were completely
in the realm of science fiction until
not very
long ago when the idea of quantum
computing to be fair was largely
an extremely stimulating um theoretical
idea so this is very exciting indeed
uh but before more ambitious
aims about reaching
uh it can be reached like um thinking of
fault tolerant
quantum computers a a positive answer to
the following
question must be reached as a milestone
along the way which is can we hope
um noisy realistic
quantum devices to provide some sort of
computational
speed up over classical
um computer classical computers and
that's kind of basically
what's at stake on supremacy
monday and not so much kind of looking
at a practical problem
solving some practical issue but just
conceptually have some task for which
there's strong evidence
that one outperforms the best classical
super computers for am the same task and
indeed
said you just gave a wonderful talk
about reaching such
a quantum advantage um realized with
a random circuit on 24
23 qubits at google apps and we will
hear
um a lot more tomorrow um
about it
um now
complementing these efforts there has
been almost at the same pace
a development of quantum
simulators so devices that offer
an enormous degree of control but not
quite enough
to be fully fledged universal quantum
computers they're in a way the the dirty
brothers
of um quantum computers but
well they exist and and they're one
thing they are large so
um the asymptotic limit is in in a way
built in say with
systems of of cult atoms in optical
lattices one can think of
devices that have 10 000 or even 100
000 sites that is to say atoms that is
to say
qubits under relatively high levels of
control and
recently one has also taken steps
towards making such quantum
simulators programmable as kind of
intermediate
devices somewhere in between a quantum
computer
and an analog quantum
simulator and
like questions that are generically
probed with such
um quantum simulators
are say ground state questions of
intricate
quantum meta or quantum materials then
kind of
dynamical questions of quenches
uh following local time revolution
generated by local hamiltonians or
slow evolutions that are in some way
reminiscent of an adiabatic quantum
computing and indeed with such quantum
simulators one can
address a number of integrate
physics problems of interacting quantum
matter both in equilibrium situations or
in out of equilibrium situations like um
anybody localization in 2d where there's
still some puzzles around
whether this phase even exists slow
quenches in 2d
beyond a cable zurich mindset and and so
on
so there's a lot to say about this but
not really
today i think for the purposes of this
talk it's important
to stress that such quantum simulations
can be performed under very precisely
controlled conditions in
one and two spatial dimensions um
and at the same time one can also do
like
classical not fits but classical
re-simulations
of the same kind of setting using the
best known classical algorithms on
run on classical supercomputers that
nicely kind of confirm what's going on
for short times
but and for short times these algorithms
can be made
in principle precise that one would even
be able to give
rise to a kind of rigorous um error
estimate
however in time one faces the
interesting situation there will be some
growth of entitlement so that
the common tensor network methods will
kind of reach a barrier from which on
one can no longer go further
to even faithfully represent um the
states
um at hand so this generates the
interesting situation that
well the experiment runs on why would
nature care of what we can
run on our classical supercomputers
where the classical simulation is rather
used to build trust
in the very functioning of the quantum
simulation
in in in in the first place so these are
kind of
baby steps of course but in a somewhat
interesting
direction in that in this mild sense
um and that's sometimes unappreciated
that
quantum simulators that exist with
present technology
are in some way already outperforming
the
best classical tensor network algorithms
for the same
type of algorithm to date in that
short times can be assessed but long
times not 1d can be assessed but two
times not
or and settings of this of this kind
of course one can always i mean for
physicists that's often
good enough i mean to to have an
advantage of that
kind but to be fair um
there's always the kind of devil's
advocate argument that
one could find a better classical
simulation algorithm
a clever technique to kind of tackle the
same
problem at hand so to be safe
against a an argument of a lack of
imagination one must
prove the hardness of the task that's at
stake in a complexity theoretic sense
and using
a language of um computational
complexity and this is basically what's
at stake
on supremacy day on on showing a a
quantum advantage over a classical
computer
in in one way or the other
so what we have a look at in the
rest of the talk is in what way we can
think of
schemes showing a quantum advantage not
so much
on like complicated or integrated
quantum circuits
amounting to high levels of control but
in
in a similar simple fashion based on
short short-time hamiltonian evolution
that's in some ways
reminiscent of a
analog hamiltonian quantum simulation
then what advantage would that however
we will see that kind of this
acute element coming in in in the way
such settings can be more stringently
verified
in their functioning compared to other
schemes
that show a quantum advantage
now economy advantages has a lot to do
with being pedantic about things i mean
they they're not really
a quantum advantage scheme is not really
solving a practical problem after all so
it's kind of sharpening the the mind
towards what it means to have a kind of
computational advantage about over
another device so it's
it's a very good idea to be very precise
about the assumptions made or pedantic
about
the type of argument so we sat down
quite a bit um and
thought about how one could kind of
lessen the conceptual mathematical
assumptions and loopholes that enter the
argument
where we spend quite some time with um
later so here notions of
anti-concentration matter
and random circuits unitary designs
and i will take this as an excuse to
also mention
um other recent efforts building on that
as an
interlude on actually realizing unitary
designs with negligibly few t-gates and
realize what could be called
quantum homeopathy because it's a
striking and
rather surprising result where i'm
looking for
interesting applications one could think
of so i'm eager to
to hear your opinions where this setting
can be used because it's really quite
um astonishing that this um
is actually actually possible and then
depending on how it goes with time i
will
in the very end of the talk kind of
meditate a bit
ask what next might think a bit on
notions of hamiltonian or distribution
learning or
kind of ask general questions of what
next should be on the agenda after a
kind of sampling based um quantum
advantage
has been reached in the nice fashion as
sergio has just explained it in the
previous talk
now the known schemes for quantum
advantages they're based on
sampling schemes and this for a good
reason as
quantum computers are good at
sampling distributions but
um these problems can be hard for for
classical
computers so the known schemes that show
a quantum advantage one way or the other
are schemes that
produce output distributions that are
rather flat and rather
close to being uniform but for which
it's still they're still integrated
enough so that one cannot
easily resample the same distribution
on a classical device
or more specifically the sampling from a
distribution that is close in the right
sense like in the
total variation distance of a random
circuit is kind of computationally hard
with high probability over circuits if
the random circuit
is um sufficiently um long under
assumptions
that i will make more precise towards uh
later parts
of of the talk there's several variants
of that um historically there were
like boson sampling and ikp circuits
settings first and
random circuits based on how random
unitaries or other
universal gate sets came into play so
the scheme realized by
the google team was basically a variant
of a sufficiently deep random circuit
that was implemented
in in santa barbara and this is a
spectacularly interesting scheme where
one does have a random circuit
implemented giving rise to
the distribution for which there's
strong evidence that
a classical supercomputer cannot
approximate
um the distribution generated by
the quantum scheme
so how would one um
find out whether when has whether one
has done the right thing
in in in in the first place and there's
several ways one can think about the
problems
andre has very beautifully explained
different
schemes and different mindsets with
which one can address
um the questions maybe the most
stringent way
of addressing the question is to take a
device-independent black box
verification mindset and just
basically go into the lab stare at the
data generated and say
oh if the data are right then you say
the data are right and
the green light goes on and if the data
are not so much right
and the noise levels are too high than
the red light
would um would go on that's basically a
black box verification test
slightly more precisely stated
a black box verification test with a
sample complexity m would be an
algorithm that takes a binary string as
an input
and would in the hypothetical situation
of having precisely the right
distribution
and realized except with probability
like larger than two-thirds but if the
distribution is off by
more than epsilon in the total variation
distance then the probability of
accepting
that um output would be like smaller
than
one-third and one would call a black box
verification test as sample efficient
if the number of um specimens drawn
would polynomial
would be polynomial in the in the system
size now that this is an argument
on the sampling complexity and not the
computational complexity so one can
give the the algorithm uh
unlimited computational power to come to
the conclusions really about
what samples to take and not about the
computational complexity
of running this specific algorithm
now in this mindset
of course there is distributions that
can be black box
verified if the distributions are rather
rather peaked then one can easily see
that um there's black box verifiable
settings from polynomial many samples
but
if the distribution becomes too broad
and it's anti-concentrating then there
are settings where
every black box test requires an
exponentially
large number of samples to um come to
to a conclusion and the proof tool that
is behind that is um is kind of
cute it's the the funniest norm i've
encountered in my life
a feature is strongly here which is the
the p
minus max minus absolute on two thirds
norm which is
you take a probability distribution
you chop off the largest element
then you chop off the smallest element
summed up until you reach epsilon
and of that remaining part you take the
rainy two-thirds knob
and that's kind of the the the the norm
that's in the in the
center of this um of this theory
yes can i ask a question please do so
uh yeah so this this black box uh
certifier
so this person gets the description of
the circuit that generates the samples
correct
that's correct yeah but uh you're saying
we're not
concerned about computational complexity
but in some sense it's reasonable to ask
that this person runs some classical
tests
but you're that that's that is a problem
then or
you don't want to why you're not
imposing that
i mean that that's a classical verifier
and it has you know polynomial time
algorithms only or some something
efficient yeah i mean it's just this
will be more forgiving
in that i i i ground the the verify
even unlimited uh uh like computational
power to just take that part out of the
game
um but of course i mean all inputs are
available in particular the original
input of the algorithm is available to
that setting
yes uh there is a question in the q
a uh which shouldn't take too much
uh time it says are the bounds of
two-thirds and one-half special or is it
an arbitrary choice
oh no this you're absolutely right
that's a short short question
they're completely arbitrary i mean any
number um different from one half will
do the job and you just
um iterate the argument and like any
number would go these are
completely arbitrary numbers they have
no significance right
what's a very very common way of like
formulating weak membership
and so on um
okay now the the interesting insight
here is that
um if you apply the machinery to to the
circuits at hand you find that
ozone sampling iqp circuits also random
circuits they cannot be black box
verified
from part of no many many samples that's
kind of interesting
so um in a
device independent fashion one cannot
verify the correctness of these
distributions one does need
further assumptions and surgeries just
beautifully explained like cross
entropy tests in their in their in their
in their variants to
come to um conclusions
now in the in the physics community
um like the reactions are kind of widely
ranging
um many people are quite relaxed about
such uh
such statements and there's indeed the
common prejudice that
when one thinks of a quantum simulation
to verify a quantum simulation one needs
to be able to efficiently classically
simulate it and if you can you would be
able to just
track the the quantum stimulation and if
you cannot then
the there's no way you can find out how
you can find ways to
certify the correctness of a of a
quantum simulation
never mind this is this is a kind of a
common prejudice that one
um yes yes quite often so how can i
think of
like more stringent um
ways of verifying
quantum advantage schemes and this was
actually born
out of our efforts of thinking of the
simplest
quantum advantage scheme one can think
about
in the first place it should be a scheme
like the simplest scheme that doesn't
make use of any type of control of
quantum gates of circuits
of of any kind but just of some fixed
hamiltonian short time quantum evolution
but retaining at the same time like
hardness proofs with under total
variation errors in
in in a similar a similar fashion and we
kind of worked on this for quite a while
and had a kind of an iteration of
schemes until we came up with schemes
that
presumably may be the the simplest
conceivable schemes for
a quantum advantage um of
of any sort and i will present actually
one of those
examples although i'm happy to to say
more about about
some others so there's several schemes
of this form um i will say
something about one of them which is the
one in
in the left that has some sort of
randomness other schemes have no
randomness whatsoever in their initial
stage
so what's the the scheme you
prepare quantum bits
in just some two-dimensional rectangular
array
but this initial state would not be some
complicated correlated state it would be
not a
like a high entropy state or a a a
state generated by a circuit but just a
product state
and this specific product say it would
be random but i
id random in that the qubit the state of
the qubits would be
i i i drawn from a two valued
um probability measure again that's not
set in stone there's other schemes that
have not
no randomness but here you have like
this iid randomness in in the in the
in the qubits but otherwise it's just a
purely um
a pure state which is the product state
over the 2d lattice
so if you want you can think about such
a setting
as being like the ground state of a
disordered optical lattice if you
like to think in these these terms if
not it's just a
two-dimensional setting with qubits
being placed
in a product mistake
now one lets the system go
and evolves it in time under the
to my understanding simplest hamiltonian
i'm i'm aware of
namely the nearest neighbor easing model
with perfectly commuting terms and not
for long times
but in fact for just one unit of time in
the
in the units of the coupling strength so
you just apply it once and
and that's it so since all terms are
computing
there's hardly any entanglement
generated in the entire system i mean
everybody sees only the
the assist the neighboring system
or think in the quantum circuits if you
want to
uh it's just a unidep circuit so it's
hardly any long-range entanglement
everybody sees the neighbor and um and
that's it
now with this metaphor of
code atoms and optical lattices this is
interesting that this was not only done
or is not only conceivable as a setting
in called atoms and optical lattices but
in fact this was one of the historically
earliest experiments that have been done
at all in the first place by by a team
where all these um now leaders in the
field were still all in the same group
including
um uh henge and and and bloch
greiner and so on in 2003 where
they looked at this um controlled
collisions
basically realizing a control that gate
in the hyperfine
levels this was some experimental
prescription
only later it's interesting to note um
the idea of
a cluster state was born out of that
specific
setting and then the idea of a
measurement based quantum computer was
actually
building out of this scheme of control
collisions of code atoms
in optical lattices and the third step
is
you just measure all qubits out in the x
spaces
now in optical lattices again sorry for
this
for this metaphor if you think in these
terms one can do
single side addressing with the atom gas
microscope
within some limits this may be
technologically the
most demanding step because it has to be
rather accurate but
again there are several ways one can
think of just measuring out all qubits
in the x basis there's no conditioning
no
no post selection no no nothing you just
generate images of a type and and that's
it
so the scheme is a product state
one unit of time of a commuting
hamiltonian and measuring all out qubits
in the x bases and that's that's
um so this is also borderline classical
because there's no
no conditioning no quantum gates there's
also hardly any entanglement in the
system you could
easily compute all expectation values of
local observables by just conjugating um
the circuit anyway interestingly
this is a scheme for this is a quantum
supremacy scheme
so indeed sampling up to a constant
total variation error
from constant time evolutions of
two-dimensional translation by and
easing hamiltonians is impossible
assuming three ingredients namely
anti-concentration
in that most output distributions are
not two peaked i come to that in a
minute
average case hardness in that um
the average case instance is just as
hard um the the worst case hardness
and well the polynomial hierarchy is
infinite um
like b p being np would lead to a
collapse of the polynomial hierarchy on
the
on the lowest level this is presumably
the the least
boring assumptions
and under these assumptions one finds
that
this scheme that has no no gates no
control no
no no randomness along the way just
product states
one unit of time evolution and sampling
out the setting
is a quantum supremacy scheme of this of
this type
so how does the argument roughly work in
in in in in a few words so there's again
no no gates no
no conditioning and so on but one can
show that
the statistics that one get on these
measurements is the same
as if one had done a
measurement based scheme
with measurements in the xy plane as
as a computational scheme which is which
is post selected
which in turn can be seen as if you make
a kind of look at space and time like um
that one angle one side of this scheme
would be time and
and the other one would be space that
the statistics at the very end
of the circuit is precisely the same as
if one had done a universal quantum
circuit
that is universal for both bqp that
consists of that gates control z
t and hadamard gates except one doesn't
have to implement
the circuit but the statistics obtained
is precisely
the same as if one had done this
type of universal quantum m circuit
and that's good enough to show that the
output probabilities
are sharply hard to approximate which
means that
the sampling of a distribution
from that distribution is hard up to
very small like unreasonably small
multiplicative errors in in in
in the set now these
stringent assumptions on multiplicative
errors they can be
made softer by making use of the stock
maya ethereum machinery
to relate the hardness of
this to the hardest of sampling with
more meaningful additive errors
in the total variation distance assuming
and the concentration
of the distributions to which i come
also
um in a minute so this together would
allow for physically more meaningful
constant errors in the total variation
distance for the
entire entire scheme so we were quite
happy with this
at a time at the time meaning that one
can do a quantum advantage setting with
no control no gates no circuits
by just preparing a state letting the
system evolve for one time under a
nearest neighbor hamiltonian and just
measuring what you have
and that gives rise to a a an advantage
scheme
of of of a certain of a certain kind
however we kind of um wanted to work
harder and kind of
stare more at the at the assumptions
that are entering here a lot of
anti-concentration
of average case hardness or the of the
or the polynomial hierarchy and instead
at these assumptions entering our proof
and
here we joined forces with bill feverman
from maryland and also with adam boland
from
berkeley and stared at
at these assumptions and asked questions
whether we could
lessen these assumptions and kind of
close these
conceptual loopholes by replacing these
assumptions
by stringent mathematical proofs that do
not make
further further assumptions
the first step in this along these lines
was to more carefully look at
at the at the issue of average case
hardness where we found using ideas of
interpolation between random and
specific
instances and uh using the barely
competitive theorem that
one can indeed see that it is sharply
hard to compute
like three quarters plus one over
probably n of the output
probability so that a constant fraction
of
the instances encountered are actually
as hard as
the worst case complexity which leads to
an average case hardness
of the overall setting under well at
least under perfect sampling
in in in in the scheme which kind of
significantly lessens this um average
case
hardness assumption
what was like considerable work and
um that what pretty much annoyed us in
this was this anti-concentration
assumption that the most output
distributions are not too peaked
it takes a kind of moment of thought to
realize that if the
circuits realize are mixing enough if
they are so-called unitary design
meaning that they are like a uniform
covering on the unitary group which are
uniform in the sense that
all polynomials of degree 2
are precisely giving the same value as
the averages um
of degree two over the har measure of
the unitary group that has have a lot of
applications in many many settings
um and the the impetus was on kind of
seeing that the effective random
circuits that are generated by these
schemes
give rise if the circuits are deep
enough ultimately to an approximate
to design of of a kind he had a
machinery that came into play that's
kind of
cured and maybe unexpected in this
setting namely
like rather condensed matter inspired
tools and
and methods in that the convergence
speed of an
average of a random circuit
to a unitary two design can be related
to the spectral gap of a fictious
hamiltonian local amatonia
frustration-free hamiltonian
that has to be bounded from from below
now to compute um
spectral gaps of hamiltonians is a
notorious problem
but for frustration free hamiltonians
there are quite some tools available
like
um canada bounds nafta gator bounds to
prove
lower bounds of this quantum anybody
hamiltonian and by that
show the convergence to an approximate 2
design and from that show
that the distribution generated is
having
the right anti-concentration property
meaning
say the convex of a concentration bound
in that the the probability of having
outliners is not too small
in that the distribution is is a rather
flat
distribution in in a very precise sense
and this and the concentration that is
commonly used in the assumed in these
settings like in
boson sampling is you're not assumed to
be true but really
um proven to be valid in the setting
i'll buy it at
pretty heavy costs and hard hard work
but this loophole
was kind of um settled as a as well
so when going through these assumptions
so we basically one by one
kind of lessened or removed the
assumptions going in except that the
polynomial hierarchy is still infinite
as kind of a complexity theoretic
underpinning of all this that's probably
there to stay but
under very mild conditions one can see
that
the sampling under a constant time
evolution of a two-dimensional
easing hamiltonian is impossible um
on a classical computer whereas in a
quantum setting it just
looks at evolving quantum states for
short times under
perfectly meaningful physically
plausible nearest neighbor
um
so there are near-term quantum
simulators that are
kind of intractable for classical
simulators that don't meet don't make
use of
control no quantum gates no no no
circuits but they're still intractable
for classical computers in a
quite stringent sense and most
conceptual mathematical loopers along
the way that are often
assumed to be true can be here really
rigorously
nailed down and proven in in in very
precise
uh in a very precise fashion
and in
along the way we kind of developed tools
on
how to get unitary designs that are the
kind of
as random as possible
collections of finite unitaries that
precisely
capture the ha averages up to
polynomials
of of degree and t
and motivated by all this because
unitary designs are not only important
in supremacy schemes but they're you bit
ubiquitous in quantum information they
play an important role in randomized
benchmarking in studies of
scrambling of quantum chaos of
like lots of settings like quantum
thermodynamics
you want to see how far we can go here
and think of
constructions of higher order unitary
designs
coming out of that in in in
in the first place and while
two designs are relatively easy to get
for example with random clifford
operations that
also play a nice role in
falter and quantum computing they give
rise to
approximate two designs where proximate
refers to approximate designs in diamond
gnome
it's very difficult and notoriously
annoying
to think of unitary designs beyond
designs so random clifford operations
they just don't do it
they they gracefully fail to be a for
design by
by a split margin and so one has to
think for gate sets that are universal
to think of like
general constructions of unitary designs
of of a kind so we can ask great so
clifford operations don't give rise to
designs to unitary designs
so one does need universal gate sets to
do the job but
how many expensive t gates
in a minus of t gates which a t gate
counts that
capture the expensive part of a circuit
so how many expensive t-gates are needed
to
uplift a kind of two design from um
random cliffords to a full
t design for arbitrary orders of team
and the argument involved is like very
technical but the answer
is striking and strange and not very
technical
at all that i would like to share which
is
well and one can get
designs one can realize absolute
approximate unitary designs with a
circuit depth
that goes like t to the power of four
where t is the order of the
of the design and log polylog t um
and log one over epsilon in the error of
the of the
design but with the number of
non-clifford gates that
doesn't even enter the system size like
independent
or of n so you have a clifford circuit
that's not powerful
and then like you sprinkle in like salt
the the non-universal t-gates
but you don't have to put in very much
like a sprinkle of
salt of t-gates that uplift a random
circuit clifford circuit
that's so mixing to a fully
um t design
random circuit where the number of
non-clifford universal gates that you
put in
is is completely negligible in in in in
in the settings so security the system
size does not even enter
um may some say something about the
proof tools later about this but
it's kind of interesting that one can
achieve quasi randomness with many
applications is quantum information and
in devices with
negligible t-gate counts
as a theorem but we're just exploring
experimental implications
in scrambling in notions of quantum
chaos
there must be some around so if you have
ideas of what to do with this
this seems like a highly surprising and
strange result there must be something
one can do with it so if you have ideas
please
contact me and we can kind of further um
think about um
these methods
so this brings me pretty much to the end
of my
um presentation so we yeah maybe
yes can i ask there is a question from
the audience ah very good
of the preview on the previous slide
very good
for this approximate t unitary design
what is the dependence in t
of non-clifford gates
ah what is the number of
non-classification parts you know
and this is a higher order in t
but i do not quite know this out of my
head it's like very few i mean the point
is
it's independent of n but the number of
non-clifford t gates will depend on t
of course and this will also be a higher
power it's more than four
some power of t okay so t absolutely
right so this
it's it's exp unsurprising maybe more
expensive in high
higher t but completely independent of n
and i mean if you accept that most
designs i mean the
the interesting bit is like four designs
if you don't have
two designs then um like t is basically
like a constant
but indeed i should i i say i will give
a
better answer how that that scales in t
for the
non-clifford contributions to get a t
design
yeah sure okay but thanks yeah oh yeah
okay
okay so that brings me to the to the end
of my talk which is good
39 minutes um but there's one more this
more desirable feature that i would like
to share which is
along the lines of closing loopholes
in a way which is that the type of
verification that's
in store for that type of architecture
is in a way
more direct more powerful than in in
other
in other schemes which is
it is in a way a verifiable
one can perform measurements like of the
order n measurements
like local measurements that um
can be accumulated of a type that's very
similar to the sampling that one does
anyway it's not only x measurements but
x and z but
it's basically like the experimentalist
does some experiment and sends you the
full
the full package and then you resort the
same data that you get
and make a software experiment so from
local data you can assess the noise
levels that you have in the system and
if the noise levels are too bad you say
oh dear the noise levels are too bad i
have to give up i have not achieved my
goal
the setting is too noisy but if
the noise levels are good enough and the
experimental data are right
then one not only builds trust in the
functioning of the scheme or
one kind of likes the scheme or it looks
good or one gets some
good good vibes but the data one
acquires
are giving a heart bound to precisely
the right quantity namely the
total variation distance that also
enters the complexity theoretic
argument so by by taking these
measurements one can basically verify
that the state one has prepared is a
right state
in in in in in this scheme i mean this
is not device independent one doesn't
need
quantum devices they are not
they don't have to be perfect but
they're not completely assumption-free
they're like quantum detectors
but other than that i can really measure
out the full state and has a stringent
verification
of a quantum advantage scheme and then
you say oh great
but if i can do that what what comes out
what's the the outcome of the
computation
and then you say you don't know you have
to do the experiment
you can only verify that the state is
correct
but you cannot make predictions on what
this will deliver in the sampling
experiment
it's kind of cute it's also
philosophically cute that
you can find out that your preparation
is right
without being able to make predictions
for the subsequent
measurements in in sampling experiment
but you can in a rather strong way
certify the correctness of the quantum
advantage scheme which of course
is a consequence of the specifically
simple
architecture in the first place that
makes you use of a unit depth
circuit in in in time so you can approve
and certify um the setting and we've
also joined forces with innsbruck
to um realize this um setting in in the
lab
so i mentioned this common prejudice
well judge for yourself that to verify
quantum simulation one needs to be able
to classically efficiently simulate
this um this this device
well i mean it's often stated judge for
yourself
but the good news is it's not quite
right anyway
in that there are some delicate
situations some delicate quantum
simulation that
can be verified in a very strong sense
in a
like on a bigger sense almost even
if an efficient classical simulation of
the same problem
is completely um out of reach which
generally generates a very
intricate and interesting state of
affairs
okay so that brings me to the end of my
talk um
we looked at analog quantum simulators
that already outperform good classical
algorithms in a
kind of more hands-on more physics-y
physics-y way
also but also relating to what sergio
has talked about in his a beautiful talk
in as an opening talk of this of this
event
there is the hope that feasible quantum
devices
do show a super polynomial speed up for
the same type of problem over classical
supercomputers and all this effort is
not
solving like um world peace or or hunger
or a practical problem it's it's more of
a conceptual type in that the schemes
are not fault tolerant but they can be
certified it's kind of a
a belt test for quantum computing even
if simulators
exhibit a quantum computational speeder
we just want to
show whether such a setting is um
conceivable
in principle that's great but
of course there's more to come that can
only be a first step but everybody says
that i'm not originally in this
assessment
of course you would want to be closer to
physically more
interesting schemes he made some baby
steps in that direction but
that's really a baby step more excited
we are about
our um efforts of seeing a quantum
advantage
in distribution learning in in
ways where one can see that a quantum
certain quantum oracle access can show
an advantage
in distribution learning compared to
only having classical
oracle access to to a to a distribution
where
arguments of currents and pseudo-random
functions come into play to
show this um separation
then if the way forward is to think of
analog simulation in the first place
that tackle interesting
problems one better knows that the
analog simulation is doing the right
thing after all i mean this is something
that i have not really spent
much time with but then this question
comes back on
on the on the radar and with the google
team with our friends
around pedram rauschen and ben chiaro we
are really at high speed
trying to finish a paper on robust
learning hamiltonian learning of quantum
simulators showing that
from data alone one can infer that the
hamiltonian one actually has in the lab
is fairly
close to the anticipated hamiltonian one
would like to see
in the lab and this problem despite
sounding very trivial is a pretty
intricate and
nasty question if you want to have a
robust
learning algorithm where ideas of super
resolution come into play and
and a bit of non-convex optimization you
had to work quite hard to
have a scheme that is actually in a
reasonable fashion
robust to noise and any time i hope
this this paper um will come up
so as my last like ascii
line um we are all aware that
there's come some some massaging of
quantum algorithms in in
in depth and um and and size
so one can kind of
play with circuit depth versus system
size
so this scheme that we had a look at
here or
that was in the center of the of the
presentation is interesting
in the way it constitutes the extreme
form
of such a trade-off in the sense that
the circuit if you want to see the time
evolution as a circuit was actually a
unit depth circuit
so it's only space and no time that's
hardly enter any entire
in the system it's unit depth only space
and you still get a computational
advantage of this
unidep quantum device over
the best classical supercomputers and
with this i
thank you very much for your attention
i'm looking forward to the
questions you might potentially have
oops thank you very much
all right thanks jans see should we wait
from
for some questions
i'm not very good with this um
question answer thing
okay i'm just opening it
uh sorry and let me ask a question um
hello yeah yeah sure um i cannot really
read the game
it's better when you say it in words
yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay so um i'm not sure
the this it is
these uh res quantums that can be
at least in practice generally simulated
you know up to a certain day
and um so how do you how do you
reconcile exactly what you're saying so
what was the difference here
oh there was a hiccup in the connection
at the beginning of your statement can
you read
the beginning of your question please um
yeah
the at least in practical terms so what
is that square away with what you're
what you're doing is a slight difference
in setting or
what's what's the bit for
oh um
yeah uma's connection is really bad so
uh
yeah i i'm not sure oh i'm sorry
imagine history
um so okay i i can only guess
okay i can guess like make a kind of uh
hashing
well i make a guess about what you have
asked and then i i say something about
this and then you say
is that connected to your point so i
mean so
it's it's your your question related to
like how different
is such a scheme from other from other
schemes
and i would say it's it's i mean
on on the physical level it's extremely
different
i mean the key inside is that in a
setting that's physically extremely
different i mean there's no
gates there's no conditioning there's no
um i mean even the the the the
the topology is largely of no relevance
and so on and in a very different
setting
you can uh formulate a scheme
so that the output statistics that you
encounter
is actually provably very similar
to the output statistics in random
circuits
that have been analyzed also before so
the kind of the big step is to see that
physically extremely different settings
relate to a machinery of random circuits
and so on that has been established
before but
given that the scheme is so different
you have also other tools available like
uh local certification i mean you just
make local measurements and
since there's hardly any entanglement
you just have to look at
very small supported um
objects to fully learn the state in
all detail and glory which you you
wouldn't be able to in any other scheme
you kind of see what i mean or have i
answered a random question on a
a random part of your question
yeah sorry i'll have to ask you later
because
maybe my my connection was is really bad
so oh i'm sorry yeah but i would love to
hear what you would what you have to say
um
i i catch you up later
okay
there's a question and answer thing why
can't i see this
um yeah there is quite a lot of q a
uh actually it's piling up as we speak
but i
i would like to suggest the uh protocol
that you
yense that you uh get onto it
in the coming uh time uh
uh maybe at the beginning of the next
talk and see if you can answer
by text because that's a bit how the q a
is set up
okay can be answered and everyone can
see
the answers that you type into those
questions
that sounds perfect yeah absolutely
i mean i can't see them now but i will
figure out a way to see them
uh you better plug in your computer
first
uh okay
okay great so uh i don't know can we all
thank the speaker again virtually
thanks a lot okay all the settings of
zoom have an applause button but not
that's
all that's cute
yeah okay great we have five more
minutes